y
[Música]
bienvenidos una semana más a medio
ambiente en france 24
estamos a menos de 2 meses del inicio de
la vigésimo sexta conferencia de las
partes de la cumbre climática de la onu
conocida como cop 26 que ha sido
calificada como la más importante desde
el acuerdo de parís de 2015 un momento
histórico ya que fue el primer acuerdo
legalmente vinculante contra el cambio
climático recordemos que hace seis años
casi la totalidad del planeta firmó este
acuerdo que comprometía a los gobiernos
a reducir los gases de efecto
invernadero para sus países para limitar
el aumento de la temperatura global a
los dos grados centígrados y a poder ser
al grado y medio con respecto a lo que
marcaba el termómetro de la tierra en la
era preindustrial es decir hace unos 170
años en este nuevo encuentro que llega
con un año de retraso por la pandemia de
kobe 19 los países tendrán que presentar
sus planes de reducción de emisiones
conocidos como n de cesc o
contribuciones determinadas a nivel
nacional que cada cinco años tienen que
ser más ambiciosas
durante los próximos minutos
intentaremos explicarles la importancia
de esta cumbre y el papel de los
gobiernos subnacionales en acelerar la
lucha contra el calentamiento global y
el cambio climático un rol que tienen
que desempeñar no solo durante estos
eventos ambientales sino cada día del
año para ello conversaremos con los
líderes de dos ciudades que aunque en
puntos muy alejados del planeta tienen
algo en común ambas lideran la ruta
santiago glasgow que une a la cob 25
presidida por chile aunque fue celebrada
en madrid en 2019 con la cob 26 que
inicia el 31 de octubre en la ciudad más
grande de escocia le doy la bienvenida a
ira fija a ser alcaldesa de la ciudad de
santiago y asus de knight que en ella es
líder del consejo de la ciudad de
glasgow y ambas nos acompañan por skype
muchísimas gracias a las dos por estar
con nosotros en france24 inició con
susan aiken en glasgow su ciudad es la
anfitriona de esta cop que según muchos
es la cumbre de la última oportunidad
para la acción climática global
cuál es su visión y objetivo para este
encuentro es realmente el más importante
hi spains to be here hola es un gusto
estar aquí sí creo que estoy de acuerdo
con john kerry el enviado especial de
eeuu para el clima en que esta es la
última y mejor oportunidad para
asegurarnos de que se tomen decisiones
que prevengan un cambio climático
catastrófico en el futuro
vimos y lo que queremos que se defina en
glasgow es un acuerdo de glasgow que sea
meritorio de su nombre cuando de uso 1
que se basa en el acuerdo de parís que
se construya sobre las promesas del
acuerdo de parís espero que se centre en
resultados en acciones en el terreno en
cumplir con las intervenciones que son
necesarias para prevenir una catástrofe
climática así que nos gustaría un
acuerdo de glasgow que sea realmente
algo de lo que podamos sentirnos
orgullosos porque lleva nuestro nombre
pero también que sea un momento crucial
en el que el planeta colectivamente tome
las decisiones que se tienen que tomar
para estar seguros de que podamos
asegurar un futuro mejor y sostenible
para todos nosotros en el planeta
y las dejas leer usted tomó las riendas
de la capital chilena hace apenas unos
meses explíquenos por qué las ciudades
son tan importantes en la lucha
climática
hola todas y todos mucho gusto
participar en esta instancia un abrazo
también a mi colega de glasgow y bueno
sin duda que las ciudades son el espacio
principal donde se desarrolla la vida en
común y por tanto el desafío que tenemos
como ciudad es en este caso ciudades
capitales es tremendo porque tenemos el
vínculo directo con la comunidad y es en
nuestras comunidades donde se sufren las
principales consecuencias de la crisis
climática en curso y por tanto se
implica un desafío respecto de la
gestión de residuos al interior de
nuestra comunidad así como también la
promoción de áreas verdes especialmente
antes las islas de calor que enfrentan
ciudades como en la ciudad de santiago y
es por ello que estamos trabajando
también en los planes de manejo
participativo de los parques y plazas de
nuestra comuna buscando una gestión con
la comunidad porque lo que permite al
municipio es el vínculo directo con las
personas y son las personas sus
comunidades su organización la que tiene
un desafío gigantes con respecto de
poder gestionar nuestro patrimonio
nuestro espacio público ante el desafío
que nos presenta la crisis clima es por
ello que valoramos tanto también esta
hermandad respecto de santiago y glasgow
que puede permitir un rol protagónico
desde las propias comunidades en nuestro
país que se implique también el
desarrollo de la abuela urbano con una
perspectiva especialmente de recoger el
arbolado nativo que tanto aporta también
al desarrollo de nuestras comunas y por
tanto vemos que es justamente el espacio
local el que debe jugar un rol
fundamental
especialmente cuando los gobiernos
nacionales no se han comprometido
directamente como corresponde con este
desafío
masai ken es la primera vez que reino
unido es anfitriona de esta cumbre
estaba haciendo suficiente el gobierno
nacional para abordar su responsabilidad
por la crisis climática y cómo se están
preparando los gobiernos subnacionales
ante la cob 26
y creo que todos los gobiernos
nacionales tienen que subir su nivel
algunos lo están haciendo mejor que
otros pero precisamente el objetivo de
la cob 26 para conseguir un muy buen
acuerdo de glasgow que realmente cumpla
las promesas del acuerdo de parís se
necesita que todos hagamos las cosas
mejor que todos seamos más ambiciosos y
más generosos
generes
los gobiernos occidentales y del
hemisferio norte tienen que ser más
generosos y apoyar a los países del
hemisferio sur para que también puedan
hacer su transición y que se haga de
manera justa y equitativa
y los gobiernos nacionales tienen que
respaldar a las ciudades y a las
regiones porque realmente son las
ciudades y las regiones y los gobiernos
locales quienes pueden cumplir con esto
nosotros somos quienes conocemos
nuestros lugares sabemos lo que se
necesita hacer ya sea la
descarbonización del transporte o
encontrar mejores sistemas de
calefacción de los hogares que sean
bajos en carbono o mayor biodiversidad y
espacios verdes en nuestras ciudades
sabemos lo que se tiene que hacer
los gobiernos nacionales nos tienen que
apoyar para poder obtener resultados
porque somos nosotros los que podemos
hacerlo más rápido y en muchos aspectos
más eficazmente que los gobiernos
nacionales y creo que los gobiernos son
nacionales ya sean regionales oa nivel
de las ciudades e incluso a nivel
nacional como lo es aquí en escocia se
harán escuchar de manera alta y clara
las oficinas de la ciudad de glasgow
donde estoy sentada ahora mismo serán la
alcaldía del mundo entero y aquí será
donde los gobiernos subnacionales podrán
exponer sus argumentos y sus demandas
hacia los gobiernos nacionales para
ayudarnos a poder entregar rápidamente
resultados para nuestros ciudadanos y
para el planeta
alcaldesa hasler pese a las constantes
advertencias y alertas de los
científicos se ha avanzado poco
realmente en acciones contundentes desde
la firma del acuerdo de parís que falta
en su opinión para que podamos realmente
hacer la diferencia en la lucha
climática
si hay una conciencia creciente de la
ciudadanía especialmente de la juventud
respecto a la importancia de incorporar
una visión que entiende la importancia
que tiene hoy día el desarrollo
climático y el problema que enfrentamos
con la crisis climática sin embargo
desde la institucionalidad estamos al
deber y yo creo que debemos pasar desde
los acuerdos hacia la acción y el
compromiso directo respecto de la crisis
climática y en ello creo que ha faltado
una voluntad real por parte de las
autoridades para avanzar en este sentido
y junto con ello poder es escuchar
escuchar a esta comunidad que está más
empoderada que tiene mayor conciencia y
poder tomarla en cuenta directamente
para la toma de decisiones y eso implica
también un rol desde la
institucionalidad hacia la industria
hacia los emisores a propósito de que en
nuestro país y creo que es una situación
también en el resto del mundo falta una
orientación hacia la industria y es por
ello que vemos en chile- con mucha
esperanza también el proceso
constituyente en curso que nace de la
movilización de la ciudadanía justamente
para poder poner estos elementos sobre
la mesa
y con ello poder enfrentar situaciones
que acá decimos mucho que la mega sequía
y los problemas que enfrentamos no es
solamente por la sequía es también por
el saqueo que han hecho muchas empresas
que ha hecho la industria y en nuestro
país tenemos especialmente un desafío
con la minería en ese sentido y por
tanto de poder desde la
institucionalidad escuchar a la
comunidad pero al mismo tiempo poder
orientar y fiscalizar a la industria que
está todavía muy alta respecto del
desafío climático que enfrentamos en el
mundo
ambas son líderes de ciudades que están
en regiones y ecosistemas muy distintos
y que tienen comunidades con retos
particulares
cuál es su mensaje con respecto a la
desigual responsabilidad climática
global y cómo las comunidades a las que
sirven se ven afectadas por este
fenómeno
susana que en adelante
y sabemos que las personas que menos
contribuyen al cambio climático son las
que más sienten sus efectos y esto
sucede no sólo a escala global sino
también localmente
pasan ciudades como la mía quienes menos
pueden responder a los impactos del
cambio climático son aquellos que sufren
los peores efectos
y en eso es en lo que se tienen que
centrar los gobiernos nacionales tienen
que asegurarse de que la transición se
haga de manera justa y equitativa y que
nadie se quede por fuera
va a haber una transición enorme en la
próxima década y en los próximos 20 años
nuestra economía va a cambiar los
sistemas en los que se basan ciudades
como santiago o glasgow van a cambiar
dramáticamente y nos tenemos que
asegurar de que los más pobres los que
más necesidades tienen no se queden
atrás en este aspecto
así que creo que la prioridad número uno
de los gobiernos en la cob 26 debe ser
llevar a cabo esta transición de manera
justa tanto a nivel global como local
es enormemente importante si hacemos
esta transición y no es justa sufriremos
las consecuencias por muchos años
es una ciudad como glasgow conoce bien
esto pasamos por una transición cuando
nuestras industrias previas se volvieron
obsoletas y no fue planificada y hubo
mucha gente que fue excluida así que
esta vez tenemos que plantearlo y
asegurarnos de que nadie se quede por
fuera james y las hijas leer brevemente
cuál es su mensaje con respecto al tema
de la inequidad climática entre países
industrializados y contaminantes y los
que más sufren las consecuencias que
suelen ser los que menos contaminan
la lucha contra la crisis climática es
también una lucha por justicia social
evidentemente en los distintos países y
en cada uno de nuestros países también
al interior de las comunidades hay una
afectación especial a los grupos más
vulnerables hacia la precariedad hacia
quienes viven el hacinamiento
especialmente también hacia las mujeres
por tanto una perspectiva de género
cuando hablamos de la crisis climática
es fundamental continúan los mandatos de
género a las mujeres hacia el cuidado de
las personas así como también en el rol
creciente en el espacio de trabajo
remunerado y es por tanto una necesidad
abordar la crisis climática desde una
perspectiva de avance hacia la igualdad
aquí hay países en el mundo que se han
aprovechado directamente de los recursos
que cuentan otros países simplemente
para su propio desarrollo y bienestar y
ahí creo que hay una necesidad de
ponernos de acuerdo a nivel mundial pues
muchísimas gracias a ambas y las hijas
leer desde santiago de chile- y a susana
de quien desde glasgow escocia por estar
con nosotros en france24 y a ustedes
sigan con más información
434 puntocom
[Música]